[موسيقى]
واشرت بطبيعه الحال الجانب اشرت الى جانب
اخر يتعلق بسياسه الرئيس سركوزي
وهو ما يسمى
بالربيع العربي هذه الاحداث التي نظر
اليها من قبل البلدان الغربيه كانها مرحله
انفتاح وتغيير لكن الامور غالبا ما انتهت
بطرق
عنيفه وفي ليبيا الوضع كان عنيف جدا لانه
كانت هناك حرب اهليه وجاء تدخل
العسكريين في ليبيا
بمشاركه 53 دوله وقرار للامم المتحده
وجامع الدول العربيه ولكن هذه العمليه لم
تكن مخطط لها بطريقه جيده وتنفيذها لم يكن
جيدا من حيث النتائج وصحيح انه في النهايه
الت اليه الامور الى مالت اليه الت الى
وضع ماساوي وتداعيات هذه العمليه غير
المخطط لها بطريقه جيده هذا امر يجب ان
نقر به اليوم فهذا بلد
لا يمكن او ليس هناك حكومه تحكمه
انتشار اسئله
[تصفيق]